dans toute la france on le sait les
grandes entreprises ont été invitées à
créer des jardins collectifs pour en
distribuer la production à leur
personnel les ouvriers et employés de la
corporation de l'automobile pouvait-il
trouver un endroit plus propice que les
apports de l'autodrome de montlhéry 51
hectares ont été cultivés ce qui a
permis de distribuer à chacun des 80
mille ouvriers de la corporation 5 kg de
pommes de terre
il faut souhaiter que pareille
organisation qui permettra d'apporter
une certaine amélioration aux
difficultés actuelles de
l'approvisionnement soit imitée par de
nombreuses collectivités